today's new member of the day is Henry
Kim bhaiyya Henry thank you for being a
supporter of the show really appreciate
the fact that you're saying sign me up
I want to be a supporter of progressive
independent media that I agree with also
thanks to Lexie Paz lei Lexie Paisley
who's today's sustaining member of the
day who has been with us nearly five
years
you can join Henry and Leslie by signing
up at www.thatsgreatnews.com
caller from 207 who's there hey TJ
what's going on yeah the other thought
the other day I had a thought about the
14th amendment and my state Maine and
Vermont we allow inmates to vote right
but could the argument be made that any
states that permanently revoke the right
to vote are in violation
yeah I've heard that before I mean I've
read that before and you can make that
argument but it's not really been tested
to my knowledge at this point and I
think that there is sort of a better
path forward which is that fighting it
on constitutional grounds is a much
longer process than doing what for
example states can do directly via
ballot questions and just reinstate
those voting rights so I think that you
you're what I've heard before but there
are other paths forward yeah also I have
this other thought about taking the
Senate ok enough too
pity into double date well that's been
proposed with California as well and
it's not quite so simple to split states
up particularly when one region of a
state is significantly more responsible
for the financial viability of a state
and there would be I mean that that's it
I don't know how simple it is to create
more states I think that you may be
overstating that simplicity TJ ah ok the
call I belong I'm gonna let you go I've
got a bunch of people here holding on
but it's great to hear from you